1m34
73 ans je m'aperçois que j'ai une belle
vie malgré l'handicap de ma petite
taille
j'étais considérée comme une sorte de
d'être anormal de paria qui devait
supporter toutes les misères à tel point
que j'ai cherché à me suicider
sa Makari sera brillante bachelier avec
mention docteur en droit à 26 ans avec
un premier prix au concours des thèses
par rencontrer sur son chemin
bien des personnes
capables d'envisager un mariage avec
nous mais il faut reconnaître que la
femme a un esprit de charité de bonté
Jean moi et chaque fois que tu parles de
charité Dieu sait si tu en parles je
pense que on ne se marie pas par charité
je t'ai apprécié et je t'ai aimé tel que
tu étais